let me ask you about more
what's the role of War and Peace maybe
even the Big Love and Hate in that part
of the world because it does seem to be
a part of the world where there's
turmoil there was turmoil there's still
turmoil
it is so unfortunate honestly it's
it's such a waste of human resources and
and and
yeah and human mind share I mean and at
the end of the day we all kind of want
the same things we want you know we want
human connection we want joy we want to
feel fulfilled we want to feel
you know a life of purpose and
I just I just find it baffling honestly
that we are still having to Grapple with
that
um
I have a story to share about this you
know I grew up beneath I'm Egyptian
American now but but you know
um originally from Egypt and when I
first got to Cambridge it turned out my
office mate like my PhD kind of you know
she ended up you know we ended up
becoming friends but she was from Israel
and we didn't know yeah we didn't know
how it was gonna be like
um did you guys sit there just staring
at each other for a bit
actually
turns out
emailed RPG pH advisor
asked him if she thought it was going to
be okay yeah
um and oh this is around 9 11 too yeah
and and Peter um Peter Robinson our PhD
advisor was like yeah like this is an
academic institution just show up and we
became super good friends we were both
um new moms like we both had our kids
during our PhD we were both doing
artificial emotional intelligence she
was looking at speech I was looking at
the face we just had so the culture was
so similar our jokes were similar it was
just I was like why on Earth are our
countries
why is there all this like war and
tension and I think it falls back to the
narrative right if you change the
narrative like whoever creates this
Narrative of War
I don't know we should have women Run
the World
yeah that's that's one solution the good
women because there's also evil women as
well true okay
[Laughter]
um but yes yes there could be less war
for women around the world the the other
aspect is uh it doesn't matter the
gender the people in power
you know I get to see this with with
Ukraine and Russia different
um parts of the world around that
conflict now and that's happening in
Yemen as well and everywhere else
there's these uh narratives told by the
leaders to the populace yep and those
narratives take hold and everybody
believes that and they have a distorted
view of the humanity on the other side
in fact especially during war you don't
even see the people on the other side as
as uh as human or as equal intelligence
or Worth or value as as you you tell all
kinds of narratives about them being uh
Nazis or uh Dom or whatever whatever
narrative you want to Weaver on that or
evil
uh but I think when you actually meet
them face to face you realize they're
like the same exactly right it's an
actual big shock for people to realize
like
um that they've been they've been
essentially lied to
within their country and I I kind of
have faith that social media is
ridiculous it is to say or any kind of
technology is able to bypass the the
walls that governments put up and
connect people directly and then you get
to realize oh like people fall in love
across different nations and religions
and so on and that I think ultimately
can cure a lot of our ills especially
sort of in person just I also think that
if leaders met in person to have a
conversation that would have that could
cure a lot of the ills of the of the
world especially in private